and it stands to reason that when we're
playing chess against each other you're
gonna capture with some piece or pawn of
mine and I'm gonna capture some piece
and pawn of yours and that's called a
trade if you capture my pawn and I
recapture your pawn we traded pawns when
you just leave a pawn on pre or you
leave your pawn and your opponent just
captures it for free well that's not a
trade that's just a mistake I made lots
and lots and lots of mistakes i
blundered my queens i blundered my rooks
i blundered my bishops but i really like
this idea of a trade how many of you
like trading like when they capture your
bishop you want to capture theirs right
I like trading but then I began to
discover that trades aren't even even
when they're even they're not even that
some side usually benefits from a trade
so this began a very sophisticated idea
I began to get really better as is
instead of automatically trading I began
to think who benefits who benefits
let me give you an example let's suggest
why opened with this queen pawn the pawn
in front of his queen is a queen pawn
opening he plays the move d2 d4 black he
understands that in the opening you got
to control the center and he does the
same move these happen d5 games pretty
even right very even white thinks to
himself hmm
what should I do next
what should I do next and white thinks
that he would like to put his epon on
the square III but before he makes that
move he hears the cry one of his army
one of the people in his army cries if
you play III says the bishop on c1 you
blocked me move me out first
so white says okay I'll move my Bishop
out and he plays the move Bishop f4
black says okay I'll develop my army
I'll play Knight here and white now
plays the move III and the bishop says
thank you thank you now I'm not blocked
in the bishops on a good diagonal so
what so black gets the same kind of idea
he thinks that he would like to move his
pawn to e6 but he doesn't want to block
his LightSquared bishop so he says I'll
bring out my LightSquared Bishop and
I'll play the move Bishop to g4 and yeah
and the the black player Pat's himself
on the back because he says it's even
stronger than your Bishop move because
this Bishop move attacks the Queen okay
yes young man yes now we now white has
to decide how he wants to deal with this
terrible threat this terrible threat
that he his queen is going to be
captured well we can't allow that so we
have to decide what we want to do young
men right first we got to make sure that
we can't take the bishop and probably
when I when I started I would have taken
the bishop and then when the knight
takes my queen I would have cried can I
have my move back please can I please
have my move back
all right exactly this moment one of the
things we like to do there are elements
in chess there space time force pawn
structure and King position what we like
to do in the opening is make sure we're
developing our pieces and we do that
using the time count exactly at this
moment the score and the time count is
one two three four white white has moved
three of his units in this case two
pawns and a bishop the score for black
is one two three
so exactly at this moment we could say
pretty much that in the time count it's
even now let's deal with the threat of
this Bishop attacking the Queen one
thing we could do is we could block the
bishop with our pawn that's a good move
in the sense first of all we don't lose
our queen yay
our pawn does attack the bishop so we
win a tempo that is to say if the bishop
doesn't move we're gonna take it so the
bishop had better retreat is there
another way of dealing with this threat
how about an aria Bishop to e2 this was
the move I was looking for okay so black
threatened White's Bishop if black
threatened whites Queen blocked the
threat and offered a trade of bishops so
this is where I was starting my lecture
about is this idea of who benefits from
the trade trades happen all the time in
chess so we have to carefully weigh who
gets the better deal when we trade so
after the move Bishop e2 white is
threatening to capture blacks Bishop and
that would win a piece so black decides
to trade bishops Bishop takes e to what
should white play what's a good move for
white arjan again Queen takes Queen
takes e to now we stop we stop for a
moment is this an even trade absolutely
three three bishop bishop but but now
ahead because we count we made an even
trade but to whose advantage we count
the development one two three four one
two a moment ago it was three and three
now suddenly White has a lead in
development the trade of the bishops
benefited white in addition to now
leading four to two white also has a
threat a double attack we would say he's
threatening to go Queen b5 check to the
King and also to capture this pawn on b7
we're going to go back we're going to go
back to this moment because in fact
white does have all kinds of moves young
men
Knight to e2 is another good move but in
this case for example let's go Knight to
e2 b 7 e 6 the score would be 1 2 3 4 1
2 3 4 more or less even in the time
count if we go back one more move we
could have played Bishop e2 Bishop takes
e to Knight takes e to not recapturing
with the Queen but with the night and we
still have an advantage for white
White's bringing out his pieces faster
in the opening doing that developing
your pieces early in the opening is
crucial to your becoming a master in
chess you start developing your pieces
early and often chess mastery will occur
bishop attacks white is not the most
sophisticated player he didn't play the
best move Bishop e2 but he doesn't he
does play a very reasonable move he
blocks the threat to his Queen by
putting the knight in the way now what's
the score in the time count 1 2 3 4 4
black 1 2 3 black to play black now does
something that we would say is a mistake
he takes the knight white recaptures in
the material count what's the score
it's an even trade right but in this
trade who benefited the most young man
what do you think who benefited the most
why why did white benefit more than
black
correct one two three four one two white
benefited so we're gonna go back to this
moment and black black realized what you
just said he didn't take the night black
decided to play pawn a six and now we
have one two three four one two three
four white to play somebody give me a
good suggestion for whites move young
man h3 is an excellent move h2 h3 this
is called this type of move is called
putting the question to the bishop the
bishop is asked the question do you want
to take my knight yes or no if you take
my knight we we know who benefits
so black decides to retreat with his
bishop exactly at this moment what's the
time count young man in the brown yes
yes so this move was beneficial for
white white got to play the move h3 for
four for free h3 is a good move I'd like
to take the move h3 back for a moment
and ask once again what's another good
move for white another good move young
man
Bishop e2 Bishop e2 is an excellent move
is an excellent move and we're going to
go with that move for a moment it
develops a bishop and it prepares to
castle okay now it's black to play the
score is one two three four five one two
three four black needs to make a good
move would this be a good move two
thumbs down
right that's what don't even think about
it you're taking a develop piece and
retreating and making it undeveloped
piece in fact that would be a terrible
move and white would be very happy no
because then you undeveloped two turns
in fact this you've moved it one time
and you moved it one time back at the
moment one two three four five one two
three four
now you guys who were just playing a
little while you're playing the games
chess you count when you capture your
opponent's rook you say I won five and
then he captures your Bishop you count
that you're ahead in material right you
do that I do that I it matters to me I
like to be ahead of material so I can't
material but I also count time and now I
would like to play the move Bishop to d6
and let's think about this for just a
moment what what's happening 1 2 3 4 5
so I consciously say to myself oh that I
like that move Bishop to d6 because I
develop a piece off the back rank I'm
prepared to Castle and check this out
I'm offering a trade i when I offer
trades I'm awful I'm always carefully
trying to weigh who benefits most are
young
black is better because he has more
space okay the space count is something
completely different from the time count
at the moment this pawn has to in the
space counter-attack ce-5 and c5
this night has to so that's for this
Bishop one two three four so that's
eight black has two four six seven eight
nine a little bit more space
yes are generous ooh
correct so what does that mean
which means maybe black didn't have more
votes that well the Queen at the moment
neither Queen attacks the other player
space let's go back and think about the
time count for a moment black has just
offered a trade of bishops okay now yes
in men yeah would how many in the class
would take the bishop raise your hand
trade bishops how many of you would
Castle pretty good how many of you would
drop the bishop back to g3 okay those
are the three primary moves we're going
to consider for white tassels dropping
the bishop back to g3 and trading
bishops let's look at each move and turn
and try to weigh the pluses and minuses
if I take the bishop the Queen
recaptures so it's even right even trade
but who benefit it black
why'd why did black benefit young man he
got to develop his queen so the result
was one two three four five one two
three four white who had the first move
has fallen behind in the time count due
to the trade of moving the bishop twice
and bringing the Queen it now let's
let's consider a different alternative
castles black to play black decides to
trade bishops okay White has to
recapture and let's say black castles
okay sorry
who's ahead that's a good question one
two three four five six one two three
four five six same
so in that case of that trade neither
player really benefited except black
might try to make an argument he might
try to make the argument that these
pawns are doubled and the pawn structure
has been weakened without White's pawn
structure because it's been doubled as
weakened that's an argument may not be a
good one but that's what I could
possibly say let's go back for just a
moment and we get this position and
white decides to play our gems move
bishop g3 pretty good okay it's true
it kinda does nothing it loses a tempo
we drop back with our Bishop but we have
a we have a at rappy idea you do what I
what trappy idea do you think it is but
let's imagine that black says I like to
trade oh I love trading pieces
Bishop takes g3 black decides to trade
now a crucial opening principle you
should always remember this a crucial
opening principle is capture towards the
what center capture towards did you all
know that it seemed like most of you did
that's pretty good
capture towards the center what does
that mean if white were to capture with
his effort pawn would this be capturing
towards us no so capturing towards the
center requires us to play h2 takes g3
following our principles now something
very sophisticated has just happened
that I want to share my insights with
what's the time count count with me
and four wait a minute this isn't here
yeah I keyed it I'm really good at
cheating moots so you guys counted and I
tricked you
you guys counted five to four that's not
the way I counted it how did I count it
I counted it like this one two three
four five
just like you did that I counted one guy
extra I counted six
I didn't move the rook the rook has not
moved but I yes I consider the rook
developed because the H file is now open
ah so that's a very sophisticated way of
looking in the first place white does
have a lead in the time count let's say
white place here 1 2 3 4 5 2 3 4 5 6
white to play let's say white plays here
ok so at this moment I say that white is
ahead really primarily thanks to this
rook now again black wants to trade
pieces who he loves to trade pieces and
the black player plays the move Knight
to e4 ok how many of you like this move
this is a good move right it brings you
jump into the center of the board you
develop your pieces how many like this
move how many think well maybe it's not
so good maybe how many of you aren't
sure not sure ok
I think it's a bad move let's analyze
why 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 1 2 3 4 5 I'm going to
trade Knights
ok so from the material count it's an
even trade correct
now our knight has to move let's say I
move my knight I'm attacking the pawn on
e4 and I'm attacking this Bishop on g4
what should black do that's a good move
for black
yes let's do it
so now Queen Bishop takes the bishop the
Queen takes the bishop so once again we
have an even-steven trade in terms of
material but now what's the count one
two three four five six one two three
whoa whoa how interesting is that
even though the materials completely
even all the all this happened is three
sets of pieces have been traded White
has a huge huge advantage in development
now black sees that this pawn is under
capture in fact for free
in fact if white was to play this white
would take away one in the development
for black one in the drug and there
would only be two units from blacks
developed so black what should black
choose what can black do young man yes
please what's a good move
what's the move f7 f5 now this does
defend the pawn on e4 one two three four
one two three four five six it's
actually funny black is lucky that a
combination doesn't work does this move
work Queen h5 check g6 the sacrificing
our Queen work well look ahead time out
how many say yes
how many says no okay the people who
said yes I love your attitude great
attitude it's a no though we take the
Queen correct remember a moment ago I
said how the Grandmaster thinks that the
rook is developed because of the open
this is an example you take the room now
exactly he moves King you take the Queen
and boy oh boy are you a happy camper
because at the end of the whole deal
both guys got Queens both guys got rooks
and white exotic fun that's brilliant
except ah the combination that was so
beautiful
has a flaw Arjun what blocking the check
to the King this is called a skier if
the king was forced to move the rook
would secure the Queen but because black
has oh now it's really tragic we gave up
our queen for a rook and
d'arnot hate that let's go back exactly
one of the things how many of you have
seen those chess books that say a
hundred winning tactics a thousand
winning tactics all of those tactics
that win how many of you seen those
books well I used to read them and I
didn't understand them I thought they
were unfair because every combination in
those tactics worked a lot of the
tactics that I played failed so this is
an example of a tactic that fails check
here thanks to that night blocking move
okay let's go back for a second and
let's imagine we're going to look at
this move at five in a moment but let's
imagine that black had played Knight f6
okay so we're going to do the time count
thing again one two three four five six
one two three
what's wrong with that move why does
that move a bad move do you know do you
see it do you see a chance for white
here
well it does that's what it does but at
least it protects it well our young
Queen to be 5 check check to the king
boom and also winning upon so black and
blocked the check but white will win
upon the reason why this threat exists
is because white has a lead in
development when your pieces are better
develop you're going to have threats
that your opponent will not have let's
go back and see this move fi after f5
protecting the pawn one two three four
one two three four five six white leads
and development we say do not attack do
not attack unless you're ahead in
development if you have a lead in
development your chances of a winning
attack are much better than when you
have less development so in this
position white feels justified in
continuing and to develop his attack
what move should white play just some
suggestions Arjun he could go Queen h5
check provoke a weakness and maybe just
go like Queen h6 for example you'd be
threatening maybe to go Queen g7 and to
take that rook
that's an idea oh I'm sorry another
suggestion for white what's another good
move there's got to be lots of good
moves come on kids come on yeah
queen-to-be five that's a pretty good
move putting pressure on this pot maybe
if you go queen bee five he could defend
the pawn with a rook or maybe you could
defend the pawn with the queen not sure
that's a good move I like both moves
give me another move and then pawn f3 I
like that move a lot I like the move
pawn f3 a lot in the first place I
haven't moved that pawn before so I'm
developing that helps my development and
if I force black to trade i unde
it's now one two three four five six one
two three
so I like that move very much thank you
for that suggestion as well why didn't
nobody suggest castles you didn't I
didn't hear you but if you castled this
would be a very good move because now
it's one two three four five six seven
eight one two three four that would be a
very good move long castles but nobody
suggested Queen C four how come how many
of you like the move Queen C 4 now that
you've seen it yeah that's a pretty good
move because what do we call this pawn
by the way do you know what the name of
that pawn is backward yeah base pawn
that was the word I was this pawn on e7
supports the pawn on f5 and the f5 pawn
supports a pawn on e4 so we would say
that these pawns are kind of a chain
they're linked together that this pawn
supports the whole chain if we remove
this pawn then this chain could all fall
so Queen c4 at
tax the base pawn how could black defend
upon it man yes Queen f6 Queen f6
defends the pawn as does Queenie 7 Queen
f6 what would you do if you had blacks
position he rights position now yes take
that Queen no precisely Queen takes e7
at the end of all of this trading
operations white will end upon up so I
will just make one other comparison
opening comparison and the whole point
of today's lesson is to to to make you
think about something before you trade
just Queens or rooks or bishops or
Knights or ponds before you make an even
trade we understand we're going to
blunder pawns and bishops and rooks and
knights but before you make an even
trade ask yourself the question who
benefits this opening has been planned
been played for hundreds and hundreds of
years at the moment we have a king pawn
opening one to one right and we're going
to transport we're going to continue
into what is called the Rui Lopez white
brings out his knight that's two attacks
the pawn black defends the night so it's
two to two now in the 15th century from
Spain there was a Spanish priest by the
name of lope has
and the Spanish priest was credited with
this very natural move and it's called
the look Rui Lopez opening the Royal
Lopez
White's idea is he develops his bishop
to attack the knight that is defending
the pawn on e5 right white started with
the King pawn he developed his knight
now the score is 1 2 3 2 2 and black
puts the question to the bishop pawned a
SEP a 6 Bobby Fischer when he had this
position as white he mostly retreated
his bishop but a certain moments in his
career he captured the night and this
was called the ouya Lopez exchange
variation black recaptured now what do
we have an even trade right even trade
very good but who benefited the most
from this trait first let's consider one
two one two three ah young man what's
your thought okay there you go we have
an urgent will who benefits whose
right so at this moment at this exact
moment it's 2 to 3 okay so we would say
that black is ahead in the time count
it's white to play so first of all who
thinks that black benefited most okay
who thinks that white benefited the most
you see it's a split I'm telling you for
a hundred years they've been arguing
this position the first point what is to
notice is that again it's three to two
but this pawn on e5 the defender has
been eliminated and so the question
arises can't white win upon by just
capturing the pond the answer is
unfortunately no with the move Queen d4
black does a double attack he brings his
queen to d4 attacks the knight on e5
attacks the pawn on e4 and when the
knight retreats black benefits in this
trade it's an even pawn but White's King
is placed in check so we're going to go
back we're going to go back to this
position instead of capturing the pawn
immediately white castles now let's
analyze one two three four one two three
now we're threatening to take the pawn
this is a crucial moment in the history
the move f7 f6 defending this pawn is
considered very good Black has other
moves Bishop here Queen here Queen f6
and Bishop g4 I'm going to come back to
Bishop g4 in a moment I want to look at
this old this is what we would call the
class
sickle move f6 now white plays the move
D to d4 okay let's continue black
usually captures the pawn
oops white captures black captures white
captures now what's the time count
that's your time 1 2 3 or 2 3 so a
moment ago black was ahead suddenly
White's ahead but it's black to move
these questions of a tenth of trading
and trying to get ahead in this in the
time count are critical to your becoming
chess champions if you can understand
when to make a trade and when not to
make a trade your guys are going to win
a lot of games I'm going to play black
for a moment and I'll play the move
Bishop g4 one of the benefits that black
got from that trade on c6 is that he got
a bishop against tonight it's considered
that a bishop is a little bit better ok
1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 white to play I'm going
to play a move for yourselves I'm going
to play the move h3 ok just a moment and
I'm going to play for myself the move h5
now I want you to think just think for a
moment you just attacked my bishop I
went oh take my bishop I ignored your
threat I challenge you to take my bishop
think for a moment here comes the
question how many of you would like to
take the bishop yes how many of you say
I don't want to take the
well more me I would like to take the
bishop okay so first of all can we guess
what would happen if we took the bishop
fella okay let's think about that
hold on I'm gonna be giving up a bishop
one bishop for only upon who won it this
is so unfair for ya you so I mean that's
terrible
I'm a chess grandmaster and I'm sitting
here telling you guys to make that trade
you guys got a terrible teacher okay you
guys are ahead of the material count I
congratulate you
what's the time count
think carefully think like a Grand
Master what is the time count young men
what do you think
how many think it's four to four raise
your hands if you think it's four to
four
how many of you think it's five to four
the five to four is have it why because
as a grand master even though we haven't
moved our rook we like this open file
for the rook the rook has developed
without moving young man in the blue yes
why not
why can't why can't we win upon who
would like to take upon I don't know why
ooh
Queen h4 mmm does it I'd be scared I'd
be scared of check made on h2 check made
on h1 how about the move f4 are you
g3 ooh g4 g3 and in this position it's
impossible in the near future to prevent
checkmate whoa somebody told me it was
very unfair to give up the bishop that i
checkmated in a few moves later i won't
mention any names but i just want to say
interesting right we're gonna go back to
this moment for just a moment and we're
going to say would this move have been
good or bad for black who benefits from
that trait our show because
yes so after even though the trade is
even just like this trade is even white
benefits because he gets his piece into
the game I want to thank you all for
coming I want again to challenge you
think about your trades carefully the
even heads up trade and ask yourself a
critical question who is going to
benefit alright we'll see you next week